[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
zach levi plays nfl hall of famer kurt
warner in the new biopic
american underdog which opens in
theaters everywhere on christmas and the
great actor zachary levi joins us on the
program you know that we might be
related
what yeah it might be
how talk to me your last name is pew yes
my last name's pew
you're kidding me no that's amazing yeah
wait where where did your where did your
uh parents or grandparents where do they
you know uh harken from ohio
ohio okay well
i mean
my dad was born in uh saint paul
minnesota his his dad was minnesota
based
but that's you know that northern
midwest i mean you know you go back a
generation beyond that or two and that
we could we could actually be from the
same line and both handsome actors so i
mean that's really the evidence right i
mean forget the last name
look at the resemblance look at the the
sexiness that we exude but when i was
growing up you know everybody made fun
of that last name and you had to be
really good because if you didn't it's
pew you stink
and i remember i got to cnn my first job
and my boss goes you got to change your
name
and i thought he meant my first name
because i had already you know i was in
my late 20s i had already you know
suffered the slings and arrows of having
the last name of pew
and then all of a sudden he goes no your
last name and he said take your middle
name which i'm assuming that's what you
did that's exactly what i did dude we we
we've walked very similar paths yeah i
mean yeah look
growing up with last name pew
uh teased relentlessly particularly when
you get to like middle school where
everyone is just so horrible anyway
um and then yeah you know it was
interesting when i because i always
wanted to be the actor that i am now
ever since i was a little kid
and but i'd always told myself i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna change for hollywood
i'm not gonna bend for hollywood you
know genuinely and and i got down into
hollywood and then my agent told me she
was like listen you know every time i
make a phone call on your behalf it's
not
there's always a comment it's not always
necessarily derogatory but there's
always a comment and i just want you to
know that and so then i thought and
prayed on it real hard and then
ultimately came to the same conclusion
which was if i just augmented my full
name i can still be me i'm not changing
who i am but i'm
rebranding if you will you know within
the confines of my actual name so well i
have two guys in the back who are jewish
and i had to break the news to them that
i didn't think you were jewish and they
go wait his name is zach levi can you
confirm or deny
that uh you're jewish
i am not a jew but i but but i am an
honorary member of the tribe let me tell
you i've read the child's role at seder
half a dozen times
uh
almost all of my representation are
jewish uh no i mean listen uh it is
definitely something that a lot of
people confuse i have just i have broken
the hearts of so many jewish mothers who
were so happy to see me in the marvelous
mrs maisel and were sliding into my dms
literally like these jewish moms like
have i got the girl for you and then
they would then message me later after
finding out the news after having you
know searched it googled it on online
they're like oh my my heart is broken
but you're still invited over for dinner
i'm like okay
all right so you get the script for the
kurt warner story
what did you know about him prior to
i mean you know i i knew a good bit or
rather i knew what
let's say most of us who were watching
that story go down in real time knew
and there was a good bit in there i mean
the bullet points were pretty profound i
mean that's why all of us were so
impressed by what we were witnessing i
mean there was this incredible
cinderella story obviously of this guy
who essentially comes out of nowhere uh
and that they rally around and play good
football they literally did just that
and and then you know that
you know um against the this the story
that was coming out of he was you know
stocking shelves in a grocery store not
too long before that and also you know
being a person of faith and seeing his
faith kind of manifest in that moment
and that was very cool and connective so
i knew a lot of those bits
but like most of us i didn't know
the real underlying foundation and and
and journey and ups and downs and
struggles that he and brenda and the
kids all kind of went through in order
to get to that place and and really
ultimately you know
i think that that's what makes it all
gives it all meaning it gives it all
purpose it's what gave kurt purpose more
than just this football this dream he
was chasing after he found something
that was even more worthy of his love
even more worthy of his uh you know
attention and focus and lo and behold he
he then goes and values this and
beautiful thing this beautiful woman and
her and her and her children and the
relationship and then all of this dream
that he had his whole life starts to
reveal itself and then in such an
incredible way and i think all of those
things are very much intertwined it's
why it all makes it you know not just
special but also infinitely relatable i
think all of us have had these moments
in our lives no matter where we've been
where we we have our supermarket moment
i mean i worked at a car wash for a year
and a half just trying to be sitting in
the seat right now talking to you you
know it's this character building stuff
also i think everybody's had their
version of scraping change out of their
car doors to put gas in their tank you
know those are the types of things i
didn't know i didn't know that about
kurt or brenda or any of that but it's
what resonated with me the most for sure
yeah but you worked at a a shirtless car
wash i think people should understand
that like i mean come on you got to give
the people what they want dan
but do you get how often do you get hey
shazam
oh i mean a good bit i get i get hey
chuck i did this tv show truck a long
time ago some people recognize me from
that a lot of people recognize me from
shazam i'm sure now moving forward there
may be some people that yell out yo
what's go what's up fake kurt or
whatever i don't know
um have you got a shazam to a halloween
party
say what have you gone to shazam to a
halloween no no that i mean listen you
know maybe if it was a prank that we had
set up but that's like
you know they're
you know like how you don't wear the
band shirt to the concert that's like
the band wearing the band shirt to the
band's own concert like you can't you
just can't do that
uh there's the bagging the groceries
thing that i think everybody thinks of
when they think of kurt warner with the
you know the journey there i love the uh
the story he told this about 10 years
ago to us that he got
bit by a spider on his honeymoon
oh yeah and it affected his tryout with
the bears and the bears yeah yeah he
told me that story i was like this is
crazy i mean again all the different
ways that his his journey his life could
have gone you know what what if what if
he actually was able to step up in that
moment when he when he had the look with
the packers you know he maybe they kept
him on as a third stringer i mean what
if he was behind far for all those years
and never would have got any play and
all of a sudden because he didn't end up
with the packers he ends up and then
almost gets a shot with the bears and
does it and then is with the rams and
then he's sitting there and he's waiting
you know he's biting his time and he's
and he's waiting for his moments and
then that was insane zach if he went to
the bears there would have been no kurt
warner movie just letting you know
yeah there wouldn't be no there'd be no
super bowls there'd be no hall of fame
it's about the bears not kurt that it
would have probably ended quickly and
yeah yeah and yeah those were those are
some thin years for chicago we're still
in some thin years for chicago
unfortunately okay
more important to look like kurt warner
act like kurt warner or to throw like
kurt warner
the simple answer is yes
uh all of the above um i don't know i
mean look obviously
i think
you know part of part of uh you're as an
actor part of your initial ability to be
believable to an audience is do you even
look anywhere close to who this person
is i feel like we did that pretty good
um i feel like um
i feel like kurt and i particularly the
more we've even got to know each other
the more we realize that while we are
obviously still very different people we
we we have a lot of similar dna we share
a lot of similar things and how we
see the world and interact with the
world and how we want to treat people
and the things we care about and um so
that really was helpful in kind of
finding his essence and absorbing kind
of more of who he was
and then you know i was fortunate enough
to have a great quarterback coach and my
friend clint dolezell who also played
some you know obviously college played
arena against curt and then
actually got drafted by the bears and
was there for a hot second uh did not
have the story career that kurt had but
i had about two months of this
quarterback you know crash course uh and
really did everything i could to not
just you know obviously you know try to
throw as good a ball as i could throw
and i do i feel like i got down i could
throw some dimes here and there no for
sure but really getting into the
headspace of what it means to be a
quarterback and really understand you
know how to lead your team in the huddle
under center read your uh
read your receivers and their coverage
you know try not to telegraph to the the
coverage which receiver you're trying to
throw to um
all of that stuff is is very pertinent
if you're trying to bring
a sports movie as realistically as you
can to an audience and i and i feel like
with all of that done and look i mean i
also had incredible doubles who played a
lot of football growing up and could
throw dimes far more consistently than
me and took like i took some hits but i
took the hits that i could take where i
wouldn't break and not be able to
continue doing you know shooting the
film and i had a you know a double that
like literally his whole job was like
all right bud you're going in and
linebacker boom just taking them out so
so it's a it's it takes a village you
know to bring it all to life but all the
pieces are there
your favorite sports movie is what
oh man um
[Music]
you know i honestly i think field of
dreams is probably my favorite sports
movie no it's not my favorite real life
sports movie uh
but it's i think all in all i just
there's something about it that's just
so profound and
uh and i love like it's one of costner's
best roles and um you know i don't know
it's just wonderful
hey congrats great to talk to you we
appreciate you uh joining us and let's
do it again
thank you dan it's a pleasure to meet
you man that's zac levi we're not
related
and he's not jewish